[Music]
okay everybody i am so excited today
because i am joined by the glorious
cassidy freeman aka amber gemstone from
the righteous gemstones which is out now
the first two episodes of season two so
we're gonna be talking about those so
there'll be some spoilers so make sure
you watch that first and then come back
cassidy how you doing today i'm doing
great how are you
i'm doing great so i'm so excited to
talk with you i'm i'm i love the first
two episodes of the show i love the show
in general and what i really thought was
shocking was there's this little bit of
a time jump here in season two what i'm
wondering was what was your reaction to
seeing that when you first saw the
script
well you know i think we all were hit
sent to curveball with covid and being
shut down and having to wait you know
and i think it's hard to try and create
television that was meant to be made a
year ago something that danny's really
good at is staying really present and
and so i think uh picking up where we
were felt the most authentic um and i
also think that it was an easier way to
dive right into the story lines we
wanted to bring into season two um
without having to sort of explain things
uh from the end of season one so
yeah that makes complete sense and
it's interesting because it left off
where there was this tension between
jessie and amber do you think now she's
fully forgiven him and trusts him after
shooting him in the butt
yeah i mean i think shooting him in the
butt was the beginning of regaining the
trust you know i really think
retaliation is the first step
is the first step to rebonding um
but i think more than that she just you
know she showed that she's not she's not
gonna mess around that she really does
get to to have a say and ask for that
trust back again it has been a a bit of
time and i think um you know where bones
break they grow back stronger if you
choose to heal and i think jesse and
amber have chosen to to heal and become
even more of an even team than they were
before
sure um what do you think too with the
character of amber that you can relate
to the most
from cassidy
yeah i think um
amber
above all amber loves her family and i
think she's a fighter and even though
she is going to tell you
what she thinks and she's gonna tell you
when you've crossed a line i really
relate to her ability to continue coming
back and standing up for her family and
and wanting to keep that uh that family
unit close
yeah and that's what's so awesome about
her character in this season she's
really like stepping up to the plate
taking charge which i love to see um
do you also feel like being in dramas
like longmire and now doing comedy
do you put the same amount of work into
detail and prep in like the character
study or is it less of that in comedy
no i mean i i i'll be honest i'm always
thinking about my characters i'm always
thinking about who they are and what
they would do
um
i think you know
emotional preparation when it's really
heavy it it does take work and it also
takes um i'd say the difference is more
in the moment in the moment of an
emotional scene um a more dramatic scene
i have to i have to be a bit isolated um
the key to comedy is being in the moment
with everybody else so
that i have i have to trust a little bit
more the people that i'm around in those
moments um and i really like that it
feels more like uh community camaraderie
so when you say trusts around people in
comedy is that also contributing to you
guys are improvising i'm guessing as
well on the show are you sticking a lot
to the script
yeah i know i mean the script is written
and it's amazing um and oftentimes just
because there's so much in every episode
we don't have a lot of room to riff and
go off in the edit i'll say in the
acting of it there's plenty of
improvising but it doesn't always make
it in um but it is always on the table
um as danny has said before like it's
not required but it's absolutely
encouraged and supported and that is a
really great feeling when you know
everyone in the room is gonna is gonna
cheer you on and support you taking a
chance
yeah hell yeah and it's interesting to
see who you get to kind of play ball
with this season i think it's exciting
that amber and jesse are making this
relationship with the lessons and how
was that for you was that like fun
working with eric andre was that like a
surreal experience and how he kind of
operates
yeah it was eric's hilarious and he is
he's a total force um
and he he but he i he's also a huge team
player um which a lot of people that are
that big of a force might not be able to
do he really comes in and wanted to be a
part of the team and
um look it's always hard to come in and
be a guest star or recurring on a show
that's already established and he and
jessica both just came in with with like
total fire and commitment and they're
both hilarious and they both felt really
comfortable and um i loved working with
them
yeah and speaking of just like people
that come in our force and guest stars i
think what a lot of people are going to
talk about after these two episodes is
this great scene with you mind dancing
and joe jonas is with you guys um was
that something for you on set that's
still kind of like it's a pinch me
moment are you kind of past that do you
still feel that
i'll be honest the the greatest part of
all of that was the line dancing
i love line dancing
[Music]
um it was fun because i genuinely love i
genuine like anything where i can dance
or sing or like be joyful um is just
really really fun and in watching the
edit i actually was like do they have
any shot of me where i'm not like full
julia roberts laughing um because i was
i was like cassidy shut up um it was it
was legit so fun to do and when you're
in incredible heat and working for
incredible hours uh to be able to line
dance through it was sort of a win-win
yeah um and it yeah it seems amazing you
do awesome in it like usual and
i'm excited too can you maybe give us a
tease now for the fans we've all seen
the first two episodes of maybe what's
to come for amber this season maybe like
we'll kind of expect from her
you can get one tease
oh man
um
yeah yeah amber amber is still um okay
yeah amber's amber's gonna save jessie's
butt a little bit at some point okay and
i'll just tease that
they need each other but uh but yeah
she's gonna come in uh pretty pretty
important later for him no that's that's
exciting and we've already seen so much
character growth with her and i'm
excited to see more of amber and all the
gemstones everybody the first episodes
of season two are out now on hbo hbo max
as well catch new episodes every sunday
night 10 p.m on hbo uh cassie thank you
so much for joining me today and i hope
to talk to you in the future thank you
so much